I think I gotta come clean with you  about something what I told you about my  brother yeah I told you about the  program is forced to attend and now you  shouldn't be there  don't count your chickens before they  hatch  do you understand that no something  happened  oh no exactly what the bugs been  arrested being held at Rikers Island you  could get killed in there all right you  just have a client that walked in oh  good you get another ten grand  your brother will get out where are you  how much money can you get right now oh  my gosh you think I'm doing this for you  I want to be Matt Flener  [Music]  [Music]  don't be confused just gonna make the  worse to me  [Music]  before  listen I want you covered you know you  are gonna love it  this place where we are now can be a lot  of fun if you ready you're gonna have a  good time  [Music]  you  [Music]  [Music]